foreign
[Music]
here we go
okay we're yd4 let's go E6 all right so
we're facing a French
I'm going to adhere to
my promise which is to play essentially
my main lines from here on out
in the speedrun and we're facing the
Rubenstein French of the Rubenstein
French can occur via two principle move
orders the first is the tarash and of
course the second is if you're a knight
C3 player you also have to know how to
play against Knight takes against T
takes E4 so the Rubenstein French is an
incredibly solid option for black it's
very very hard to break down
and white has a Litany of of setups that
that you can adopt there's sort of more
classical ways of playing this line with
white like if you don't know anything
about this position you're very likely
to play you know Knight F3 and then
black plays Knight F6 then you know
typically you take it and you go like
Bishop F1 to D3 but the classical setup
I think promises little to no Advantage
for white and I'll kind of give you a
bit of an outline of why that is after
the game so in the last like 15 20 years
Grandmasters have developed more
enterprising options for for white uh
that involve you know certain subtle
move orders that don't allow black to to
as easily contest the center with C7 C5
I'm going to play one of those lines in
this game I'm just trying to decide
which one I want to play there's like
maybe three or four of them
so let me think about this for a second
I think okay so disclaimer I don't know
this line that well
but we're gonna start with Knight F3
which is essentially Dairy Gore for you
know the entry point to all of this I
don't know if there's any other feasible
moves here other than Knight F3 I don't
think so I think almost everybody plays
Knight F3 and the big bro the big
jumping off point is after Knight F6
Knight F6 this is like the the tabia
Pure White has maybe five or six
possible setups I've played G3 in the
past which is a pretty good positional
line I won a nice game in this line uh
OTB again Bishop D3 is the classical
move but I think it's the least
promising of the recent uh possibilities
the move that I know has a very good
reputation among top GMS is this weird
move see through well it's not a weird
move but it's not a move that might seem
particularly imposing it's the move C3
and it's easy to misinterpret this move
and think that it's purely positional
I'm just trying to reinforce the pawn
that is what white is trying to do but a
big component of this move is that Queen
A4 check is a major idea in a lot of
these positions and in general as long
as the king remains on E8 one of White's
main tactical ideas involves quickly
developing the pieces to this a4ea
diagonal and putting significant
pressure before black has a chance to
complete their development okay so C5
now I have to remember the move so just
give me a second I'm pretty sure that
the main move is Knight E5 I'm pretty
sure that the main move is 95. but
I don't remember it with 100 degree
certainty 100 certainty it might also be
Bishop E3
or maybe there's two moves I know that
Bishop E3 is a move and I know that
Knight E5 is also a move what shall we
play
okay let's go Bishop E3
Bishop E3 looks very nice yeah it's a
developing move it puts pressure on C5
and we are just trying to play DC that's
the threat of this move is to play DC
and and to win a pawn now if black plays
CD
then we often recapture with the bishop
and the position resembles an elephant
Sicilian there's a great deal of
similarity if you draw a sort of opening
Venn diagram between certain lines of
the allop and Sicilian and this
particular line of the Rubenstein French
it's actually a very similar Pawn
structure and in the alipin there is a
line where white does this exact same
thing plays Bishop E3 and then tries to
position not a knight on D4 as you might
be used to but actually a bishop Bishops
in the center can be very very powerful
particularly here one benefit of
recapturing with the bishop is that then
the Knight can drop into E5 I'm just
going to check if this guy's okay
typically he doesn't play 15 plus 10
games
um typically our opponent plays Blitz
and bullet so probably he wanted to get
a uh get a get a speeder on gay men no
I'm always just curious you know what
our what what our opponents are rated in
like the blitz pool
okay Knight D5
so 95 is a very standard response in
such positions to okay in such positions
division B3 and the idea is very
straightforward if now we play D takes
C5 it's very easy to observe the black
plays Knight takes E3
now we can trade queens and that might
appeal to newer players because black is
deprived of castling rights but as you
probably know and the Queens are off the
board that is a lot less significant
right making the king move and the
problem was after F take C3 Bishop takes
C5 not only has black recaptured the
pawn but we are left with a very poor
Pawn structure on black has the bishop
pair so DC is out of the question
completely
another tempting move that I think is
not effective is Bishop B5 check
immediately which is ineffective for the
same reason that Queen a4check doesn't
do anything black just plays Bishop D7
and you're essentially helping black
develop so I think this is the perfect
time to situate a knight on E5 I think
this is where we should play Knight E5
and the purpose of this move apart from
just sort of centralizing the Knight is
also to prepare Bishop B5 check and in
some situations to prepare Queen A4
check in both cases Bishop D7 is no
longer possible so notice that if we
play Queen A4 and black plays Bishop D7
we play Knight takes D7 Queen takes D7
and then the bishop comes out to B5 and
we win the queen
this is the direct threat created by the
move 95.
yeah very common idea in in the
Rubenstein and I'm
sort of we'll check after the game but
I'm pretty sure that this is still a
theoretical position I don't know it for
either side so I'm Flying Blind here a
little bit but all of our moves appear
to be quite sensible so I I don't think
that we're in a a great deal of danger
here with white and the Rubinstein is
not for everybody I mean Black's
position is very cramps black has to
know a lot of theory but if you know
how to respond to all these dangerous
sidelines I think the Rubenstein comes
pretty close to equalizing and if you're
a black player who is on the lookout for
a solid alternative to to whatever you
play George Meyer which is a name that I
think most people watching on YouTube
probably have come across he's a German
Grandmaster
2680 or so at his Peak he is one of the
probably the world's leading Specialists
on the Rubinstein he's played it his
whole life and he plays it exclusively
he's one of the only Grandmasters who
plays the Rubenstein French exclusively
with the black pieces there are some
other GMS who play the Rubinstein as one
of their openings like virus
Armenian American GM but Meyer is has
developed a lot of the theory from the
black side uh in the Rubenstein he's
responsible for a lot of the ideas that
have essentially revived this system
anyway it's a bit of a diatribe but I
like to give history behind openings and
the leading proponents kind of give you
a sense of
um of what you should study if you are
interested in in learning and opening A6
very good move
so A6 obviously prevents Bishop B5
and takes the sting out of Queen A4
check because thereafter Bishop D7 takes
takes we no longer have Bishop B5 not
because of a takes B5 that would drop
the rook in the corner but of course the
queen would take on B5 and we lose a
piece so
what are the options available to us
here well one thing to do
is to play D takes C5
unfortunately there I think black and
still get away with Knight takes E3 okay
and the reason why this is a little bit
of a convoluted calculation if you can
follow along in your head DC Knight
takes E3 Queen takes D at King takes d8
now Knight takes F7 check doesn't work
because when the moment we capture The
Rook black basically does the same thing
to our rook and remember that we're down
a minor piece because black is captured
on E3 and we haven't recaptured so after
DC Knight takes E3 Queen takes d8 King
txt you might be attracted to F take C3
and you might say well black doesn't
have time to recapture the plot on C5
and so we in turn get the opportunity to
secure that pawn with B4 and that is I
think a viable way to play and we will
be a pawn up in the resulting position
but in return for this Pawn black as the
bishop pair
and our Pawn structure is very seriously
damaged so it's a bit of a hard position
to assess
something to think about D takes C5 here
let me think about this DC DC
takes takes Fe King EA B4 and then the
knight from E5 can drop back to C4 and
then later to B6
which is a really attractive idea
actually
yeah I think white is better there
the alternative here is to do nothing
and to just play a one of those you know
just standard moves like Bishop to D3
because Knight takes E3 F takes E3 is
not necessarily something to fear the
reason it's not something to fear is
because the D4 upon will be very well
secured and after we Castle kingside we
will have an immediate attack on the F7
Pawn
and coupled with our Bishop on D3 which
will aim at H7 Black's King will
experience long-term problems there
now I should point out that Queen A4
check here is not bad because of B5
that's not the idea because B5 runs into
Bishop takes B5 check and you should
always be aware of this idea as long as
the rokana 8 is undefended the problem
with Queen A4 is black plays Bishop D7
and yeah we can trade everything on D7
but that's basically just a draw Bishop
B2 a little bit passive I don't like
Bishop E2 too passive I am leaning
toward playing DC but I'm not sure I'm
genuinely not positive that that's the
best move
but we're gonna give it a shot
and it's going to lead to a very
interesting end game if black plays
Knight takes C3 Which is far from Forced
Which is far from forest
and while Bishop D3 I think is more fun
at this stage in the speed run I'm
trying to play like maximally similar to
how I would play in a classical game and
probably in a classical game I would my
intuition says that we should try DC my
intuition says that we should try DC and
also we're posing black with a dilemma
right black now has to decide whether to
take on E3 or not really interesting
position I think this is going to be an
interesting game against a good opponent
okay
so yeah we've just played Pawn takes
Pawn now another benefit of this move
and you might say well the drawback of
this move is that it weakens the support
well it loses the Knight on E5 loses its
support
but on the other hand we open up the D4
Square which can be a very nice parking
spot for the bishop right if our Bishop
moves into D4 not only is it securing
the knight in securing the pawn but it's
also you know potentially aiming at the
G7 Pawn so if black plays a move like
Bishop E7 for instance right and just
doesn't do anything doesn't engage we
could respond with Bishop D4 and then
black loses the ability to take our
Bishop in the future
also note that anytime black plays F6 in
such positions you always have this
queen H5 G6 Knight takes G6 trick so I'm
never worried about black pushing our
Knight away like this at least not until
black Castle's King side
it is September so if you like my
content and you wanna
support you were already very supportive
by watching but if you're watching this
on YouTube
and you enjoy this content you feel like
it helps you improve
you know that subscribe button helps me
keep putting this kind of stuff out
so thank you to everybody for all of
your support
and the play Queen takes d8 and F takes
C3 so our opponent took a very long time
on this decision
which is a good sign I think this is a
sign that they're not totally sure
whether to go for this line or not okay
so what's going on in this position
let's try to deconstruct how do I how do
I look at a position like this and what
do I see when I when we get into this
end game right well first of all
concretely we're threatening Knight
takes F7 that is the reason why this
this whole thing works otherwise if
black could play Bishop takes E5 here we
would never go for this black has to
waste the tempo to move the king back
and black has to move the king back
because there is literally no other way
to defend the F7 Pawn black can't play
F6 because there still Knight F7 okay
now our Pawn structure is not terrible I
think visually it's quite bad and there
is a weak Pawn on E3 but that pawn on E3
it's weak technically because it's
isolated but black can't really attack
it easily black doesn't have the
Firepower that allows him to attack this
Pawn easily
what do we do after King E8 well it's an
instructive moment because I think some
people might be tempted by the move C6
and you might say well these C pawns are
doubled let's undouble or a pawn by
playing C6 but if you calculate
concretely I think C6 has more drawbacks
than benefits because what would happen
is after the trade on C6 that Knight
resulting on C6 would be very misplaced
and black would be able to play a move
like Bishop to B7 and the last thing
that we would want to do is give this
light squared Bishop this French Bishop
a you know
full diagonal to work with so we're not
just playing to keep our extra Pawn
we're also playing against blacks
Bishops we're playing to keep these
Bishops passive and as long as we keep
them passive the impact of Black's
Bishop pair is reduced that is why we
want to play B4 and create this Pawn
chain in order to keep the dark squared
Bishop at Bay should black play A5 two
things happen the first is that we could
play A3 and meet a takes before with C
takes before the second is that we get
our own parking spot for our Bishop so
I'm not worried about that
okay can you eat before yeah white is
better
now let's consider the optimal spots for
our minor pieces we have two minor
pieces right the Knight and the bishop
E5 is a good temporary spot but it's not
a stable spot should blackplay F6 here
we will definitely play Knight C4 there
should be a no-brainer to everybody
watching because we have this juicy
juicy Square on B6
potentially we have a square on D6 but
that would obviously lead to a trade and
I don't know if we would necessarily
want a Pawn on D6 because that would be
more of a weakness than a strength
um yeah probably black should play G6
but if black plays G6 and Bishop G7 then
the D6 square is opened up completely
for us so we would have to tread very
carefully because G6 actually creates a
huge threat of Bishop G7 right because
there if we drop our Knight pack we drop
C3 with tempo Bishop B7 is a very
similar move he's trying to get the
bishop to F6 and we have to address that
immediately
how do we address that how do we address
the threat of Bishop F6 well we can
address it by not addressing it we can
just Castle
and we can play Bishop F6 Knight C4 and
Sack the pawn on C3 but I don't think
that sacrifice is warranted we play
Knight B6 in that position but black
just goes Rook B8 and we're at a dead
end
yeah that Knight is very nice but we're
not actually winning any material so I
think the only way for us to effectively
address this we can go from either end
we can go and defense C3 so we can play
Rook C1 or King D2 or we can remove the
knight from E5 so that Bishop F6 doesn't
come with tempo
so that Bishop F6 doesn't come with
tempo okay
I think it's worth starting with
Knight C4 because we're gonna play this
move anyway it's worth starting with
Knight C4 because
logically speaking whenever black plays
Bishop F6 this is going to be our move
so starting with this move gives us more
flexible options if black plays Bishop
F6 also I'm trying to discourage black
from playing Bishop F6 because Knight C6
comes in with tempos that's an
additional worry the Buck has to
consider before playing Bishop F6 and
I'm looking at our opponent's clock and
I'm saying okay six and a half minutes
if we can milk that down to like three
then the clock becomes a serious
consideration here
yeah our opponent really really taking
taking his time
notice that it's interesting black
really can't move these pawns so this
weird construction which I should say
arises out of a lot of different
openings the C5 B4 C3 thing is very very
good at winding down any potential
counter play on The Queen side as long
as we can keep that intact I think we're
in very very good shape
okay so this is
hard to explain but I actually think we
should hold off on Knight D6 check why
because after King E7 first of all we're
helping black potentially connect his
Rooks and second of all
it's it's like the kinetic versus
potential energy that I've talked about
in previous streams where as long as the
Knight is on C4 its options are open we
can go to B6 or we can go to D6 in some
cases we could even go to A5
we don't want to commit to a placement
before we have to like Knight D6 isn't
going anywhere we can play this move
whenever we want to and I want to wait a
little bit longer for black to sort of
put his cards on the table if that makes
sense so we're going to start with King
D2 in order to secure this Pawn why am I
playing King D2 and not Rook C1 well the
typical advice is that you shouldn't tie
down your heavy pieces to like a menial
task and this is a great illustration of
that Rook C1 would be a very bad use of
our resources
I might say well isn't the king the most
valuable piece well it is but it's also
the piece that's not really
participating in the game yet
so a great spot for the king would be
out of the way on C2 where it would be
defending the C3 Pawn but also away from
the D files that Rook d8 is really not
that dangerous
okay
so I think to find a good move here we
need to ask ourselves what Black's next
move is going to be
black snacks mode is likely to be Rook
d8 check but in itself that that is not
a dangerous move a very good learning
moment I think for for newer players
like don't just be afraid of a move
because it looks like a scary check why
is Rook dhek not a scary check well
because we're able to shift our King
over to C2 what we really need to be
paying attention to is this bishop on C8
how is black going to go about
developing that Bishop well most likely
black is going to go Bishop D7 and
Bishop C6 and try to get it to the long
diagonal so what I think we should do is
start with Bishop E2 I think it's very
important for us to immediately get this
bishop out of the gates in order to meet
Bishop D7 with Bishop F3 and essentially
beat Black to the long diagonal right oh
and a lot of these end games really do
hinge on concrete details like who can
get their pieces to a particular Square
first or set of squares first black
could also be playing E5 but that would
create a serious complex of light Square
weaknesses in the center and it wouldn't
really change what we did we would still
play Bishop F3 and put serious pressure
on the B7 Pawn
also possible would have been to play
Bishop D3 and then Bishop E4 but I I
like the F3 Square because it's a
defended Square I like the F3 Square
because it's a definite Square defended
I mean by a pawn of course so
interesting subtlety black and play
Bishop D7 here right and the move Bishop
D7 carries a potentially unpleasant
threat of Bishop either Bishop A4 check
and then potentially the only thing
stopping Black from infiltrating to D2
would be this relatively flimsy
Knight on C4 not a situation I would
necessarily want to allow so in response
to Bishop D7 apart from Bishop F3 who
can tell me a possible prophylactic move
that we could consider there's actually
several prophylactic moves that we could
consider yeah I'm talking about the move
A4 essentially advancing the pawn and
preventing the Bishop from accessing
both the B5 and A4 squares now you might
say well doesn't that defeat the whole
purpose of what we just did Black could
play Bishop C6 but then we meet Bishop
C6 with Bishop F3 immediately disarming
immediately disarming Black's bishop and
this other Bishop on F6 is completely
it's it's its influence is very scant
because all it's doing is staring at
this pawn and this Pawn is incredibly
well defended so this bishop on F6 is
actually a terrible piece and this is a
good lesson in not just looking at a
piece and looking at how many squares it
controls but really understanding what a
piece actually does what does it do for
your position and the answer here is
nothing the bishop does nothing
also possible is to play Knight V6 by
the way but again I like the way that
this Knight is placed here I think we
should keep it on C4 as long as we can
and only decide on a placement you know
a little bit later
let's go A4
as we planned initially
the other thing I like about the move A4
is that later on we can obviously play
B5 and we can start advancing our Pawn
majority Okay so
yeah I think black's position is
probably borderline lost here I would
maybe say I don't know
okay
yeah Bishop F3 obviously
Bishop F3 obviously no this is not
resignable in a GM level again I would
definitely not even consider resigning
here with black but if Magnus was
sitting across from me I probably would
so now we move to the next stage of the
game this previous stage which lasted I
would say six moves right was aimed at
completely disarming blacks Bishops we
have succeeded in that task we have
disarmed both the blacks Bishops now the
final stage I think has to be converting
our extra pawn and actually making
something of it
we shouldn't generate a follow-up move
because it all depends on what black
does on his next move like if black
takes on F3 that changes the pawn
structure black might play Brook ac8
something like that
but our
there's many ways that we can go about
playing this position like we can
try to get B5 in but the move B5 is very
very risky because it leaves the C5 Pawn
undefended so if black plays in this
position Rook ac8 I definitely think we
should not insist on pushing B5
we can also work on
controlling the D file so like a move
like Rook HD1 could be considered of
course we have to be very very careful
because we don't want to blunder A4 with
a pin and as somebody in the chat
suggested you could consider the move
King B3 in some cases although once
again King B3 yields the D3 Square
so whenever you're holding your
opponent's pieces back like this you
have to be very very careful not to
accidentally give up a square
it's very very easy to blunder that like
you just you know you you miss the
forest for the trees okay he takes F3 we
take back that's fine
Android kc8 yeah I think this is the
logical approach so now that there is no
longer pressure on the A4 Pawn I think
it makes a lot of sense for us to play
Rook id1
um I think this makes the most sense by
far
again I want people to see that I'm not
rushing to jump my knight into D6 or to
B6 the Knight on C4 is perfectly placed
it's controlling everything and there's
no reason to move it yet is the exchange
of Rooks beneficial to White I would say
the exchange of one pair of Rooks
definitely is
but the point of Rook D1 isn't so much
to exchange Rooks it is as it is to
contest the D file contesting the D file
it challenges Black's last source of
activity in this position if we can get
the D file under control then we can
just completely focus on converting our
four on two Pawn majority on the king
side also black is very low on time he's
under a minute because he doesn't know
what to do there's just like no moves
here black is paralyzed black is
completely paralyzed
G6 yeah I mean he basically has to
resort to waiting moves
yeah Knight A5 is possible
let me think about this E4 Maybe
E4 E5 and F4 is interesting
Rook D6 is possible
A5 is possible
the key is not to rush here the key is
not to hurry you won't be able to win
this game in like one second
I'm liking the look of King B3
for now
okay let's start with King B3 just
moving the king a little bit closer into
position because later on after the
Knight moves out of C4 we can play King
C4 and maybe even prepare B5 after all
I want to bring the king a little bit
closer okay so our opponent is like
essentially making waiting moves on the
queen side or on the on the king side I
guess now I think
Knight A5 is possible
Knight B6 is again possible but I like
the look of Rook D6
I like the look of Rook D6 which is a
classic move this is a completely
classic idea where you you put a piece
along a certain file in order to prepare
the other piece of that kind to move to
that usually this is done with two Rooks
of course but you can also do this with
a rook and a queen but there is just no
other squares along the D file that make
any sense
I mean Rook D4 may be possible but why
even consider an exchange stack here
there's no need for that instead we put
it on D6 now what am I intending after
Rook takes D6 what should I capture with
the answer is the Knight right because
capturing with a pawn gives you that
temporary hit oh it's like a check but
after the king steps away notice that
the Knight is actually going to be
paralyzed because of the weakness of the
C3 Pawn so we want to keep the pawn
structure as it currently is
take Stakes and we're putting pressure
on our opponent's clock which is totally
legit strategy he's got no time
now let's bring the other Rook into
position Rook D1 this is the whole point
of our entire approach which is to get
control of the D file
and now I think we proceed to the final
stage
I'm actually going to play H3 here just
to restrict our opponent's pawns and not
allow any kind of activity with G4 there
is no hurry black is not threatening to
take on D6 okay
now let's think about this for a second
how do I want to arrange this
King C4 is interesting by the way hmm
there must be some easy way here to
finish this game off
Knight back to E4 as possible but then
he plays F6
we play B5
C4 is possible A5 is possible
it's actually not quite Elementary to
convert this annoyingly so this is the
hardest part of the game
yeah King C4 I don't love the look of
because it walks into a pin I think I
know what we should do
but I don't want to give counter play
either
okay
yeah I'm trying to find the queen a
clean way to win here
and it's not easy to do
I think I'm gonna go Knight to E4 and
let me explain my logic
what is Black's biggest source of
counter play here in the long run well
Black's biggest source of counter play
is to create a pass on it this is like
the answer to that question in most end
games how does black creative pass upon
well black plays F5 and then G4 right so
what I'm trying to do with the use of
this Knight is to freeze Black's King
side Pawns why am I freezing blasting
side pawns well what well what that
helps me do is focus on converting my
Pawn majority without having to worry
about black suddenly creating a past
Pawn of his own this is a slightly risky
strategy because I am opening up the
door for a rook trade
but my intuition tells me that the Rook
trade is winning for white and there is
one specific line that I calculated
which I think is very important
and that line is what if black plays
Rook D7 here this is what I was like
focused on calculating
this black kid push the beep on now but
that merely plays into our hands I think
B6 B5 should be winning for us
okay there we go and here's what I
calculated
takes could somebody tell me what
tactical move
wins a pawn for white wins another Pawn
for white white to play this is this is
what I what took me like two minutes to
find yes F4 we push F4 and we knock this
bishop out of E5 and after the trade on
F4 we take F6 with check and then we
come around and take H5 but it's still
not the end of the line because after we
take the H5 Pawn who can tell me where
black can move this bishop to completely
dominate the Knight
yeah Black's Bishop can drop back to E5
and in that position we have to ensure
that we can extricate the Knight either
through tactical means by distracting
black on the on the other side or by
maneuvering the king to E4 and
dislodging the bishop which is exactly
what I want to do which is exactly what
I want to do and I think that that
should be the winning idea I am going to
renew my reservation this room for
another 15 minutes
takes
here
okay
so what's going on here how do we how do
you look at this position well here's
the thing black is threatening to play
King G6 what should white play here what
do you guys think do we need to rush
with King E4 or do we have another Tempo
that we can use for instance to fix the
situation on the queen side I think that
we should play C4 I think that we should
play C4
and only after King G6 do we play the
move King E4 but the magic of this line
is not that the magic of this line is
that after King G6 King E4 black has
this incredibly nasty move Bishop C3
and you might look at this and say well
then we have to move the Knight and
black wins The crucial linchpin of
White's entire Pawn majority on B4 but
after King G6 King E4 Bishop C3 Knight
F4 comes with a check and black has no
other way to approach this Knight so
this is an inevitable line
and now we win the game because once the
Knight is extricated successfully and
then we play B5 our strategy is very
simple we have way too many past an
extra point we can even sack the Knight
on D5 and that should be winning but no
reason to be extravagant here we can
combine pushing the H Pawn with pushing
the C pawn and there's too many passers
we're gonna make a queen very shortly
foreign
we can play Knight D3 you can play C6
everything is winning
I think the easiest is to play C6 and
create the outside passer on A6 now what
is the general rule the general rule is
that your pass Pawn should be as far
away as possible from the enemy pieces
and Corner pawns are the hardest to stop
Knight D3 the rest is obvious without
commentary we are heading for C6 in
order to dislodge the bishop and push A7
this is the final nail in the coffin we
could have also done it through B4 but
it's more elegant to do it through the
center
that's it Knight C6 and A7 is coming
and that's how we convert this Advantage
definitely not ideal but I think that
was really really nice
that was one of the nicer games that
I've played in the speedrun
opening wise and and middle game was
Gigi
okay so let's analyze quickly
yeah so this is the Rubenstein French
named after Akiba Rubenstein of course
um when was first played let's take a
look was it first played by Rubenstein
not necessarily of course as you know it
was first played in 1861 by ignats
kohlish and kolish was considered one of
the top opening Experts of the 1860s
so when when kolis wrote an article uh
he was also very rich he he struck it
rich I think in like the gold industry
or something but he was one of the top
players of the like 1850s and 1860s so
this first occurred in the game
powellson against polish 1861 in their
match and kolish played Knight F6 which
which was the old move Knight F6 is the
old move but after Knight takes F6
there's obviously a very awkward
situation for black either you have to
take with a queen and give white a big
development advantage or you have to
take with a pawn and completely ruin
your Pawn structure so this line fell
out of favor pretty quickly the first
time that Knight D7 was played was by
Albin it was by Albin in 1890 Emmanuel
Alaska was the third person to play 97
and 1894 against steinits in the world
championship match
want to hear something really
interesting
so testing your guys's attention
not Kali so some people are confusing
polish with colleague k-o-l-i-s-h want
to hear something interesting
so coalish was the first person to play
the Rubenstein French the first person
to play Knight D7 was Albin and the
tournament in which he played this was
the Coalition Memorial
what are the odds of that so Coalition
died in like 1880 and in the Coalition
Memorial at Adolf Alban who is of course
the originator of the album counter
Gambit himself
which is E5 played Knight D7 for the
first time in the Coalition Memorial
funny coincidence
um and that game continued Knight F3
Knight F6
and Philip mightner his opponent played
Bishop D3 here which is a move
his opponent played Bishop D3 here which
is an old move it still played sometimes
takes takes Knight F6 Etc
I'm sure he wasn't aware of this game
when he was playing it
so anyways Knight takes f696 F6 and this
is the sort of one of the critical
positions in this whole line so the most
popular move according to the database
by far as I said is Bishop D3 but this
line is I wouldn't say toothless but
it's not very dangerous anymore black
immediately plays C5
and the way that the old old people used
to play it is they used to play DC
Bishop C5
Castles by castles and obviously here
the most natural move in my opinion is
Bishop G5 but after Bishop G5 black
plays B6 and develops this bishop to B7
most people play Queen E2 and Rook D1
very tempting setup but after Queen C7
this position has occurred hundreds of
times and this is completely equal white
has not a shred
of an advantage here despite the
apparent weakness of Black's King
because Black's Bishops are aiming
directly at White's King side
white can play Bishop B4 but
um the games here mostly end in draws
because you're going to get a bunch of
trades on the D file
and Black's King is much much safer than
it appears on h8 there's just no way to
attack it
this is basic Betty yeah this is what
you don't want to play with white you
don't want to just Waltz into this line
because you're not going to have an
advantage
so there are many many venomous systems
that have been developed in recent years
after Bishop D3 C5 there is this
interesting move Bishop to E3
you can also play the one line that I
really like is Bishop E3 here
and the point of Bishop E3 here is
actually to prevent black from playing
C5 because here obviously you can play
DC
so this is a very interesting move as
well we're going to focus on the line
that I played which is C3 who was the
inventor of the C3 variation so the
first person to play C3 was
um Bola slavsky in 1947 and boloslovsky
was the Soviet GM
he was the first person to kind of
understand
this idea
it was played twice in 1947 so C3
um C5 is the main response by far
and let me double check what the main
move is here for white
yeah so this is interesting I was
actually correct for once
um there are two moves in this position
there's 95 which is the most popular
move but the move that almost all of the
top GMS have played recently was the one
that I played in the game which was
Bishop E3
95 is the more confrontational line
and after 95 typically black plays A6
and here once again there is Bishop E3
and there's also Queen A4 check
and this just leads to a very
kind of convoluted type of battle Bishop
D7 97 Queen DS ah but you see most
people who play this line just end up
going for this end game and I'll be
honest this doesn't appeal to me that
much even though white actually scores
very well in this end game
it doesn't feel to me that white is
really all that much better yeah you're
slightly better you've got the bishop
air yeah I agree
but I wouldn't recommend this to most
players
that's one of the reasons why I don't
love Knight E5 I think Bishop E3 keeps
more options open in just a more
interesting line
okay so Bishop E3 right in this position
the main move for black
is Queen C7 yeah Knight D5 is a mistake
I think Knight D5 is a no it's been
played by some GMS
95 has been played by some GMS
but it's far from the most popular move
and apparently the engine doesn't like
it
um let me turn stock for Sean for a
second just to double check that yeah
Knight D5 is an inaccuracy because of
let's see yeah because of 95. and it's
plus over minus already this position is
already terrible for black
fascinating
so black has to play in this position
the move
Queen C7 Which is far from obvious that
Queen C7 is the correct move
why is Queen C7 the correct mobile it
puts the queen in a much better spot and
it protects the C5 Pawn okay so it
actually is sensible to play Queen C7
here you're defending C5
but according to the engine white is a
little bit better after 95 95 A6 Queen
A4 check
and here's the thing
after Bishop D7 Knight takes D7
if you compare the two versions of the
end game this version of the end game is
much much better than the one we just
encountered because here King takes D7
runs into DC so black has to make this
very awkward recapture we can already
castle and it should be
plain to you that white has a big big
advantage in the sentient
so of course black can also cover with
the Knight right black and go Knight D7
here you can go Bishop to B5 which is a
very very typical idea in any line where
there is direct contact with an
undefended Rook on a you should really
Hammer this into your head that you
should be aware of this idea
off the top of my head one line in which
this is very important is in the jabala
London of course I will give you an
example from the jababa London there is
a line
in the jababa London C5 E3 takes takes a
six by the three Knight C6 95
and in this position you're supposed to
go Bishop D7 but people used to play
Bishop F5 and now I plays G4
and I had a game like this against uh
Daniel yuffa this is an old line that's
pretty well known
and here
there is a very interesting idea
that involves playing Queen D4
and the whole point is that after E6 who
can tell me
how white develops a huge initiative in
this position white to play and on this
tactical detail hinges this entire
variation Queen a4check but what happens
if black just goes Queen D7 well this is
your chance to put into practice what
you just learned of course it's obvious
when you get to this position but
you know try finding this like five
moves ago Bishop B5 of course and again
The Rook N8 is undefended black loses
the exchange if black plays B5 you still
take on D5 here the point is not that
The Rook is undefended it's defended
it's that after King E7 you get
checkmated beautifully look at this
diagonal Checkmate you don't even need
the other Bishop it's made in two
okay so that's just off the top of my
head this is an important pattern
now let's go back to Bishop B5 in this
position what is the point of Bishop E5
here what is this actually threat well
this threatens to win a pot it's
actually quite simple you just take
everything on D7
um notice that if CD there's Knight B6
hitting the Rook important detail you
could also take in the other order
actually no see this is this is what's
amazing about modern openings is how
much attention to detail you have to
have as a matter of fact you have to
play Queen D7 here because if you play
Knight takes D7 instead black suddenly
has the Intermezzo B5 hitting the queen
and then recapturing in a much better
version so actually you should play
Queen D7
and at the end of the line you just play
DC
and you are in time much like we did in
the game to support the pawn with B4
so if we rewind to Bishop B5 black has
to play C takes D4 and this happened in
the recent uh fide World Cup in the game
Panama against berkish Bishop D7 Bishop
D7 Queen D4 and according to the engine
white has a small but stable Advantage
why does white have a small but stable
Advantage it has to do with the superior
piece activity and the fact that black
is very cramped and the fact that black
does not have an easy way to develop the
dark Square Bishop obviously
because you will drop the G7 upon
and you know black can play Rogue d8 but
then we castle queenside and black is
paralyzed along the D file why is black
paralyzed along the D file because if
black moves the bishop
we trade everything on d8 and we take F7
it's very hard for black to circumvent
this problem because the E8 square is
occupied by the king so black and play
have six here
but that leads to this kind of position
which should be apparent to you is
rather unpleasant for black because
there's weaknesses and the King on E8 is
stranded okay so I actually think this
is one of White's best lines
um in any case the move for black is
Queen C7 the engine also gives Bishop E7
at a low depth just developing the king
side but apparently after Bishop B5
check Bishop D7 Bishop takes D7 Knight
takes D7
what is the move here for white
it's D5 oh but
yeah D5 with an edge well obviously
white is better here this is a very
unpleasant position for black from a
strategic standpoint because of all the
weaknesses in the center
yeah so so there is no easy way for
black to solve his problems but this
position is already very unpleasant
because because black has to burn a
Tempo on A6 there is no choice if black
just nonchalantly develops well this
check is very very bad for black I mean
I don't even want to analyze this
position it's clearly terrible
so black has to burn a Tempo and A6 and
that we just gobble up upon we just
freaking gobble up the pawn it's already
plus two if you can believe it stockfish
gifts plus two for white because black
essentially has to take on E3 there is
no choice
if black plays Queen C7 here trying to
pick up the pawn who can tell me what
White's response to this move is going
to be what happens after Queen C7 yeah
it's basically losing already
we need four check right that's the
whole point you induce Bishop D7 you do
the classic trade on D7 and you just
stick your Bishop on D4 or you can even
Castle this isn't even cuter move
because you pin the Knight then you put
your Bishop on D4
and then suddenly you circle around
and then Circle back to D4 and you have
a stable healthy extra pawn and a
technically winning end game
so black is just not in time so our
opponent takes on E3 leading to this
terrible terrible end game for black
terrible end game
um and I think I did a pretty good job
of explaining this end game during the
game so I'm not gonna like beat a dead
horse
Bishop B7 is logical Knight C4 is
logical
King D2
Bishop B2 this is a very important move
Bishop B2 because we are optimizing the
placement of the bishop and we're
putting it on the long diagonal and
notice that we're not afraid of the
completely paper tiger check on d8 we
just shift the king over
then we play A4 prophylaxis Bishop F3
would be very bad because of the check
on A4 followed by Rook D3 giving away a
ton of squares
so I just want you to notice how
patiently you have to play these types
of technical end games always ask
yourself what your opponent wants even
if the position is passive there might
be these hidden threats
and you don't want to give away counter
play for free so A4 is kind of a
no-brainer controlling a ton of squares
and then disarming the bishop
and then contesting the D file
and then improving the king
and then preparing to take control of
the D file from Black
and again this is an instructive moment
now according to the engine C takes D6
was possible
and what's interesting is that this
loses to D7 and Knight B6 kind of a
classical pattern
now what should white do in this
position who can tell me
in this position what is White's best
move instructive moment ask yourself
what black is threatening and try to
prevent it ask yourself how black is
threatening and try to prevent it
so A5 is the best move A5 prevents B5
because of the opposite what did Black
want if you made a move like E4 black is
already winning after B5 because you're
dropping C3 with devastating effect
always think prophylactically in the end
game first and foremost how can I
prevent my opponent's ideas black is
paralyzed and we can win by like
eventually pushing our Pawns in the
center like E4 E5 Etc
so we decided to take with a knight and
kind of keep the status quo then again
prophylactic thinking right this was a
very important moment
I thought about going to C4
and then I thought about playing
something like Rook D6
but after F5 suddenly black is about to
create a past plot and if things get
really dicey again you put the Knight on
a square where it prevents black from
making the most of his Pawn majority now
we improve
and now it's easy take stakes and F4 and
now you use tactics to complete the
circle
forcing all of this now notice that if
black would have played F5 this would
have directly led to a losing Pawn end
game so that's not option
but you can't stop here I had to seeking
D3 King E4 I had to see this because
black is only two moves away from
winning the Knight and potentially even
winning the game
so you use your king to dislodge the
bishop but before you do that you play
C4 yes probably this is also winning but
this is a lot dicier this is a lot
closer to a draw
notice that we play King E4 with Tempo
and we play Knight F4 with tempo and
something I said at the beginning of the
speedrun which is that as we climb to a
higher and higher rating the margins
become thinner and thinner and thinner
notice how thin the margins of this
Victory were even though even though I
was essentially winning out of the
opening
still when push came to shove I had to
calculate a very precise variation in
order to actually complete the Victory
and this is one of the things that
happens as you get better at chess is
you need to walk a narrower path you
need to tread more carefully and so your
calculation becomes more important
because you miscalculated a critical
moment and all of your effort
essentially is in vain
okay B5 in the game is over
so that's one of the one of the
interesting takeaways of this game apart
from thinking prophylactically
but notice at how many moments I decided
to withhold my own ideas and play
prophylactically let's count
okay one Bishop E2 was a prophylactic
move because we're trying to get the
bishop to F3 and prevent black from
getting to C6
two stopping Bishop A4
okay King B3 is more of an improving
move
three stopping G4
four stopping F5 and G4
and then that's basically it so like
there were four critical moments where I
played prophylactically and disarmed all
of Lex ideas
and that concludes our analysis folks
definitely as an E4 player against the
Rubenstein French you should play the C3
variation hopefully you found the
analysis to be helpful I'll just end by
saying that if black does not play with
C5 if black plays
if black does not engage right if black
plays Bishop E7 then you play Bishop D3
castles and black can play like this but
black is much worse here because the
ship essentially has sailed for black if
black suddenly plays C5 now he loses the
tempo black loses the tempo because he's
he went Bishop E7 and then Bishop Dixie
five so Queen E2 and then you castle
kingside and you get basically an
improved version of the classical line
okay so you can look at this a little
bit more on your own but my
recommendation against the Rubenstein
officially is to play C3 all right guys
I think we're going to conclude here I
hope you enjoyed the game it's a long
stream but a very productive stream we
did two speed run games so these will be
out on YouTube very shortly
and uh that's where we are going to end
thanks everybody great match today
against montlickov as well I'm pretty
pumped this is a good stream
thanks everybody thanks for hanging out
today I'm gonna head out
foreign
[Music]